en este vídeo vamos a tratar de checar
varias formas de representar moléculas
orgánicas y después vamos a terminar
viendo las estructuras en las de enlace
línea que son la forma más común de
representar una molécula así que tenemos
la fórmula molecular de 3h 8o
ok tenemos eso y eso nos dice cuántos
átomos átomos tenemos en esta molécula
así que si quisiéramos dibujar la
estructura de la de lewis
esto tendría tres carbonos vamos a poner
los tres carbonos aquí está el primero
el segundo y el tercero verdad y de
hecho tenemos varias formas de
representar esta molécula una de ellas
es por ejemplo si pusiera yo el oxígeno
aquí en medio tenemos el oxígeno de aquí
en medio y de hecho pues vimos en en
vídeos anteriores como cómo realizar
estas estructuras de lewis
creo que así se pronuncia lewis ok
entonces podría ser que el oxígeno se
encuentre en la molde
de carbono de enmedio verdad entonces lo
único que nos falta poner es acomodar
estos hidrógenos verdad y en los enlaces
posibles que puede haber de hidrógenos
con los carbonos pues tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
6 y 7 verdad tenemos 7 lugares posibles
en donde pueden caer estos hidrógenos
así que tenemos que localizar donde
puede donde puede entrar el último
hidrógeno y eso es en el oxígeno verdad
aquí es en donde puede entrar el otro
hidrógeno y necesitamos completar el
octeto verdad necesitamos que este
oxígeno tenga sus 8 electrones verdad
aquí tiene aquí le faltan 2 electrones
libres 2 pares de electrones libres en
este oxígeno y aquí ya tenemos la
representación o más bien la estructura
de puntos de lewis ok para esta molécula
que es el 2 propanol o que también se le
conoce como isopropanol o alcohol
isopropílico
de hecho esta molécula la puedes comprar
o el alcohol isopropílico lo puedes
comprar en cualquier farmacia y aquí ya
tenemos la estructura de puntos de lewis
completa nos muestra todos los enlaces
todos los carbonos todos los hidrógenos
y todos sus enlaces y cualquier enlace
que haya en cualquier molécula en esta
molécula pero hay varias formas de
simplificar esto así que vamos a ver si
podemos dibujar otra representación de
esta molécula y lo vamos a hacer digamos
con un poquito más condensado y vamos a
ver por ejemplo de este lado izquierdo
podemos ubicar
un ch 3 verdad tenemos un ch 3 así que
lo que podríamos hacer es no mostrar
todos estos todos estos enlaces sino
simplemente poner este ch3 o este h3c
solo todo esto condensado verdad que es
lo que tenemos después por ejemplo
tenemos este carbono que se pega si nos
damos cuenta a otro ch3 a este otro
grupo verdad a este otro radical que es
un ch 3 a este este h 3 y que es lo
único que nos resta pues simplemente
poner esto justo que tenemos verdad
necesitamos poner este hidrógeno este
oxígeno completar el octeto verdad y
ponerle su hidrógeno al que está pegado
y esto justamente es una estructura
parcialmente condensada vamos a
escribirlo así es una estructura
parcialmente parcialmente
condensada condensada muy bien
justamente porque está resumiendo
muchísima información de lo que tenemos
en la estructura completa de lewis
en simplemente esta estructura que
justamente está condensada un poco más
ok
como podríamos digamos con bet con
condensar un poquito más toda esta
información pues si nos damos cuenta
tenemos dos grupos digamos dos moléculas
ch3 así que lo podríamos poner así ch3
tenemos dos moléculas que están pegadas
a un se a un carbono con un hidrógeno y
uno o h verdad esto nos dice la misma
información sólo son varias formas de
escribirlo ok y esto es justamente el 2
propanol ahora vamos en la dirección
opuesta vamos ahora en la dirección
opuesta digamos que tenemos esta fórmula
molecular ch 32 no más bien vamos a
ponerle 3
h 3 ok vamos a tratar de escribir o
dibujar su representación de puntos de
lewis así que vamos a centrarnos justo
en este carbono tendremos este carbono
vamos a ponerlo por aquí ahí está
nuestro carbono es justo el que marcamos
y nos está diciendo que este carbono
está pegado a 3 se h 3 3
ch 3
son tres radicales metidos verdad vamos
a pintarlos aquí tenemos 1 h 13 aquí
tenemos otro ch 3 vamos a pintar uno más
se h 3 y luego nos dice que está unido
tenemos unido a un oxígeno verdad y
después a un carbono que está pegado a
tres hidrógenos es decir es otro radical
metilo verdad vamos a esto lo estamos
simplificando así que sólo ponemos ch3
muy bien y sólo para completar los
objetos tenemos que poner estos dos
pares de electrones con el oxígeno
verdad así que aquí ya tenemos la
estructura parcialmente condensada de
esta molécula que no es otra cosa más
que el éter metil ser butílico ahora si
quisiéramos dibujar la estructura
completa de ley de lewis sería c aquí
tendríamos que poner sus tres hidrógenos
tres hidrógenos tres hidrógenos y esto
está pegado a nuestro carbono que está
pegado a otro carbono
con tres hidrógenos también tenemos otro
arriba
otro arriba ahí están
esto es h y esto está pegado ahora sí a
nuestro oxígeno con sus dos pares de
electrones y a nuestro carbono que tiene
otros tres hidrógenos tres hidrógenos y
ahí lo tienen
ahora esta es una forma muy muy larga de
dibujar la molécula lleva muchísimo
tiempo de andar dibujando todos esos
carbono e hidrógeno así que vamos a
tratar de ver con otra molécula y vamos
a ver si podemos encontrar una forma más
rápida de dibujar todas estas cosas así
que hagamos un ejemplo muy sencillo
vamos a poner un ejemplo muy sencillo y
vamos a tratar de dibujar el propano que
es el c3 h 8 así que si quisiéramos
dibujar la estructura completa de lewis
sería algo así como
tenemos 3 carbonos y si nos damos cuenta
en cada uno de estos bueno en este caben
tres
en este caben otros tres hidrógenos y en
este caben dos así que justo tenemos
todos los hidrógenos
en estos enlaces que podemos dibujar con
los carbonos ahora en otros vídeos vimos
que estos átomos de carbono tienen
tienen vivir hibridación sp3 y
discutimos porque no es la mejor forma
de representarlos en el espacio verdad
así que esto en realidad podríamos
pintarlo de esta forma algo así no en
una estructura lineal y los hidrógenos
los ponemos de esta otra forma verdad
esto ya lo vimos en otro vídeo como
dibujarlo en el espacio ahí lo tienen
así que esta es otra forma de
representar el propano con nuestra
estructura de lewis pero otra vez es
mucho trabajo quien quiere dibujar todos
esos carbono e hidrógeno esto cada vez
que lo quieres dibujar así que los
químicos orgánicos tienen una forma muy
muy práctica de representar estas
moléculas y lo llaman la estructura de
enlace línea ok una estructura de enlace
líneas sólo se enfoca en
la cadena de carbonos verdad solo se va
a centrar en esa cadena así que teníamos
por ejemplo aquí 33 carbonos
y para representarlo en la estructura de
enlace línea simplemente vamos a poner
justo líneas que van más o menos así
entonces cada uno de estos vértices o
cada uno de estos digamos enlaces que
hay entre las líneas representa una
molécula de carbono déjenme dibujarlas
bien dónde están
cada uno de estos vértices representa
una molécula de carbono y ya no es
necesario poner todos los enlaces con
los hidrógenos sino están implícitos en
esta estructura de enlace línea muy bien
cada uno de los vértices lo importante
es que nos estamos centrando en la
cadena de carbonos vamos a tratar de
hacer un ejemplo distinto para que quede
más claro como cómo hacer este tipo de
estructuras por ejemplo vamos a poner
esta molécula así
h muy bien entonces esta molécula que no
es otra cosa más que el etanol vamos a
tratar de buscar cuál es su estructura
completa de lewis ok primero nos
preguntamos cuántos carbonos tiene y
sólo recordemos del ejemplo anterior que
cada vértice representa un carbono
déjenme ponerlo con azul
cada uno de estos vértices representa un
carbono muy bien entonces lo que
tendremos son dos carbonos los carbonos
unidos y este último carbono nos dice
que está unido a un o h verdad o h bien
entonces ahora necesitamos completar los
hidrógenos verdad y nosotros sabemos que
cada hidrógeno o más bien cada carbono
tiende a tener cuatro enlaces verdad
tiene necesitamos cuatro enlaces así que
aquí cabe un hidrógeno dos hidrógenos
tres hidrógenos
aquí caben dos hidrógenos el oxígeno
solo para completar el octeto
necesitamos ponerle sus
dos pares de electrones verdad y ahí
está ahí lo tienen lo importante aquí
fue que cuando los cuando éstos no
tienen cargas los carbonos tienden a
completar cuatro enlaces verdad y así
fue como fácilmente pudimos descubrir
cuántos hidrógenos teníamos vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo otro ejemplo digamos
ahora que tenemos esta cadena tenemos
esta cadena
aquí y está unido a un cloro misma misma
cuestión vamos a tratar de hallar la
estructura completa de lewis y primero
tenemos que encontrar cuántos carbonos
tenemos en nuestra cadena muy bien
entonces esto es de hecho la primera vez
que presentamos como una especie de
anillo de carbonos verdad entonces aquí
tenemos nuestros 6 carbonos que están
unidos en esta forma digamos de anillo y
el carbono de digamos superior está
unido a un cloro un cloro
y solo para completar el octeto pues
tenemos que poner sus tres en este caso
son tres pares de electrones verdad
ahora ya lo único que tenemos que hacer
es completar los hidrógenos verdad y
necesitamos completar en cada uno de los
carbonos cuatro enlaces así que aquí le
falta uno y aquí le faltan dos aquí le
faltan dos 2
y 2 verdad entonces completamos con
estos hidrógenos y ahí ya tenemos
nuestra representación nuestra
estructura de puntos de lewis completita
verdad ahí lo tienes vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo ahora utilizando enlaces
múltiples vamos a ver uno de enlaces
múltiples por ejemplo vamos a tener esta
molécula
esta molécula de aquí muy bien entonces
vamos a otra vez identificar cuántos
carbonos tenemos y aquí tenemos 3
carbonos muy bien entonces simplemente
los pintamos tenemos aquí el primer
carbono que está unido por un enlace
doble a este otro carbono y que después
tiene un enlace simple con un tercer
carbono muy bien entonces nuevamente
completamos los hidrógeno si esos
hidrógenos se completan ya porque en
cada carbono necesitamos cuatro enlaces
en este primer carbono tenemos sólo dos
enlaces quiere decir que le hacen falta
otros dos otros dos enlaces muy bien que
conectan con hidrógenos en este segundo
carbono digamos el de en medio tenemos
ya tres enlaces así que nos falta uno
un único enlace que va pegado con un
hidrógeno y en este tercer carbono
tenemos un enlace simple así que
necesitamos otros tres verdad ahí
tenemos ya toda la representación
completa de lewis y de hecho esta
representación nos permite saber cuál es
la fórmula química verdad la fórmula
digamos condensada que es se 3 porque
tenemos 3 carbonos y cuantos hidrógenos
1 2 3 4 5 6 así que tenemos 6 hidrógenos
entonces esto es también un ejemplo de
cómo podríamos obtener la fórmula
molecular a partir de su representación
de digamos de estructura de leus vamos a
hacer un último ejemplo un último
ejemplo y ahora vamos a usar un enlace
triple digamos que tenemos esta molécula
para hacerlo un poquito más
tenemos esta molécula y aquí vamos a
tener un enlace triple entonces
nuevamente como hemos estado viendo
tenemos que ubicar cuántos hidrógenos
perdón cuántos carbonos tenemos y aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 y estos enlaces triples
siempre conectan a 2 carbonos así que
aquí debe haber otro muy bien entonces
primero representamos los carbonos de
esta forma
de esta forma y aquí viene un enlace
triple muy bien entonces mismo mismo
caso tenemos que poner todos los enlaces
restantes así que ponemos todos los
hidrógenos aquí por ejemplo había un
enlace simple necesitábamos otros tres
aquí ya tenemos dos enlaces quiere decir
que nos faltan dos hidrógenos aquí este
es un caso especial porque ya tenemos
cuatro enlaces quiere decir que este
carbono no necesitan más hidrógenos
mientras que este último carbono sólo
tiene tres enlaces y por lo tanto
necesitamos un último con un hidrógeno
muy bien entonces la pregunta que queda
aquí ya que tenemos la estructura de
lewis completa es porque esto lo pusimos
de forma lineal y hay que recordar que
estos carbonos tienen hibridación esp y
por lo tanto tienen un ángulo digamos
aproximado de 180 grados de hecho en
este caso anterior estos dos los
representamos digamos no los pusimos
lineales porque éstos
tienen una hibridación sp2 y tienen
entonces un ángulo aproximado de 120
grados muy bien entonces estos fueron y
fueron formas compactas de representar
moléculas y para el resto del curso que
vamos a estar trabajando es lo que vamos
a estar utilizando